OK, we are in problem
number 9.
If 2 times x minus 3 is equal to
7, what is the value of x?
Well, this is straightforward.
Just solve for x problem,
divide both sides by 2.
Or actually, yeah, we could
do it either way.
We could say this is 2x
minus 6 is equal to 7.
Add 6 to both sides, you
get 2x is equal to 13.
Divide both sides by 2. x is
equal to 13/2, which is the
same thing as 6 and 1/2,
which is the same
thing as 6.5, right?
That's 12, yep.
Problem 10.
Point P lies on the line with
the equation y minus 4 is
equal to 3 times x minus 2.
If the x-coordinate of P is 4--
OK, so P is the 0.4, what
is the y-coordinate?
So we don't know what the
y-coordinate is, so we
literally just have to solve--
we have to just input 4 for x
and then solve for y.
So you get y minus 4 is equal
to 3 times 4 minus 2.
y minus 4 is equal to 3
times 4 minus 2 is 2.
y minus 4 is equal to 6.
y is equal to 10.
And that's our answer.
The point is 4, 10, but they
just wanted to know the
y-coordinate, and that's 10.
Problem 11.
Car A traveled 60 miles and
averaged 20 miles per gallon
of gasoline.
So car A traveled 60 miles and
got 20 miles per gallon, mpg,
miles per gallon.
Car B traveled 15 miles
for each gallon.
OK, so it got 15 miles
per gallon, right?
It traveled 15 miles for each
gallon of gasoline it used.
How many miles had car B
traveled when it had used the
same amount of gasoline that car
A used to travel 60 miles?
So they're saying we need to
figure out how many gallons A
used, and then how far
can B get with that
same number of gallons?
That's essentially what
they're asking.
So how many gallons did
A use to go 60 miles?
Well, we've got 20 miles per
gallon and went 60 miles.
So car A could do this
on 3 gallons, right?
The way you can view this,
gallons times miles per gallon
is equal to miles, right?
And so gallons, we'll say g
times 20 miles per gallon is
equal to 60 miles.
So gallons, divide both sides
by 20, is equal to 30.
That's times right there.
I'm sorry, it's equal to 3.
60 divided by 20 is 3.
So car A used 3 gallons
to go 60 miles.
And so car B can go 15 miles
per gallon times 3 gallons
equals 15 times 3
is 45 gallons.
Next problem.
OK, see if I can draw that.
It's a straight line here.
Straight line, point A comes
up to this point to B.
It comes down a little bit.
And then point C comes
down here.
OK, and they're telling us
that this is 65 degrees.
This is 100 degrees.
This is 120.
And this, right here,
is x degrees.
In the figure above, points A,
D, and E lie on the same line.
This is A.
This is D.
This is E.
They lie on the same line.
What is the value of x?
So we really just need to figure
out the value of this,
and then we can say x is
supplementary to that.
So let's think about how we can
think about what the value
of this angle is.
So the way I think about it is
draw a line here, and you
could automatically know what
all the angles in a
quadrilateral are.
But I'll prove it to you that
all the angles in a
quadrilateral are going
to add up to 360.
How do I know that?
Because think of it this way:
this angle plus this angle
plus this angle is
going to be 180.
And then this angle plus this
angle plus this angle
is going to be 180.
And if you add all of those
together, you're essentially
adding all of the angles of
the quadrilateral-- it's
late-- because this and this is
equal to the angle of the
whole quadrilateral.
So the angles in the entire
quadrilateral are 360 degrees.
And you can memorize
that if you want.
So if we know that all of these
angles add up to 360
degrees, what is this big
angle right here?
Well, we know that 65 plus 100
plus 120 plus-- let's call
this angle y, and y is this
whole thing-- plus y is equal
to 360 degrees.
And this is what?
This is 220 plus 65, 285
plus y is equal to 360.
So y is equal to 360 minus
285, and that is what?
That is 75 degrees, right?
Because 70 would
be 350, right?
So y is 75 degrees.
So this whole angle
right there is 75.
And we know that x plus this
big angle here, 75-- and
ignore this green line.
I'm looking about
this big angle.
x plus 75 is equal to 180.
So x has to be equal
to 105 degrees.
Subtract 75 from both sides.
Next question, problem 13.
The first term of a sequence
is 20 and the
second term is 8.
So it goes from 20,
then it goes to 8.
The third term and each term
thereafter is the average of
the two terms immediately
preceding it.
What is the value of the first
term in the sequence that is
not an integer?
OK.
So we just have to average
these two.
So this is going to be what?
It's going to be 28
divided by 2.
28/2, which equals 14, right?
I just took 20 plus 8
divided by 2 is 14.
And now, what's the average
of 8 and 14?
Well, 8 plus 14 is 22.
So 22 divided by 2, which
is equal to 11.
Delete my work.
Now, what's the average
of 14 and 11?
You add them, you get
25 divided by
2, that equals 12.5.
So here we go.
This is the first number in
the series that is not an
integer, 12.5.
And you could fill that in.
Problem 14.
If x is 1/5 of y-- so
x is equal to 1/5y.
y is 3/10 of z.
y is equal to 3/10z and z is
greater than 0, then x is what
fraction of z?
So you could literally just
substitute here, right?
You can just substitute
this y.
You could substitute
3/10z for y, right?
Because we say y is equal to
3 times z, so x is equal
to 1/5 times y.
We're going to substitute
for y, 3/10z.
So x is equal to--
what is this?
3/50z.
So x is 3/50 of z.
So you would fill in 3/50
in your answer box.
OK, Next problem.
Well, I don't know if I have
time to do it in this video.
Well, let me see.
No, I don't want to rush it.
I'll do it in the next video.
See you soon.